With absolutely no hesitation or shame whatsoever,
with no reservations at all about what they
were saying, Fox News host Maria Bartiromo
and former Trump economic adviser Larry Kudlow
suggested that Joe Biden might have such serious
dementia that he may not even know where he
is.
He may not even know what he's signing, and
that he may not even really be the president,
that it actually might be Susan Rice, who
is a sort of shadow president because Joe
Biden is so unaware of his surroundings, almost
like a weekend at Bernie's type situation
that they're suggesting.
Now, I could say a lot of things in advance
of watching the clip.
Let's first look at the clip to orient ourselves
and then we'll talk about it, because it turns
out President Biden may be really giving his
first couple of weeks the most left wing president
we've ever seen.
National Review editor Rich Lowry wrote a
great column on this.
His actions on spending and taxing and regulating
on immigration and fossil fuels and other
cultural issues.
He may be the most left wing.
I don't know whether he believes this stuff.
I don't know whether he's an empty vessel
for the far left wing of his party, but they
are moving in the wrong direction from day
one.
Yeah, well, that's why I was going to ask
you, who the heck is coming up with these
ideas?
You know, some people feel like Susan Rice
is running things.
Does President Biden understand what he's
signing into law here with these executive
orders?
Well, that's a good question.
Look, I'm not going to I'm not going to get
into, you know, as the alert or not alert,
he is who he is.
I knew Joe Biden very well a long time ago,
but not for the last eight or 10 years.
Joe Biden might be an empty vessel, they say.
Who's coming up with the things that Biden
is doing?
Well, maybe it's Susan Rice who's a shadow
president running the show.
Biden might not even understand the things
he's signing.
Is Joe Biden even alert?
And that when you talk about alert, you know,
it's a reference to this medical term that's
used x3.
When you observe a patient, they're oriented
in three ways to person, place and time.
It's like the most basic medical observation
you can make about someone as to whether they
have even the cognitive capacity to know where
they are and when it is talking about is Joe
Biden even alert?
So let's go through this in pieces.
When Donald Trump was president, there were
such serious questions about his cognitive
state, the slurring, the not realizing people
he's talking about are actually right in front
of him getting off Air Force One and wandering
off and having to be brought back by a Secret
Service agent.
The sort of glitching and verbal interruptions
to his speech that were very strange, talking
about the orange is of an investigation.
The citrus fruit, of course, appearing to
have no memory whatsoever of things that happened
shortly before, arguing with people combatively
about his cognitive state in bizarre ways.
And numerous neurological and mental health
experts sounded the alarm about Donald Trump.
And we talked to some of them about it.
And I would also ask those expert experts,
when I would interview them, I would say,
what do you see with Joe Biden?
Because there are people on the right talking
about Joe Biden, dementia, cognitive decline.
And all of these experts said essentially
versions of the same thing, which was Joe
Biden seems to have the type of slowdown that
you see in more than 50 percent of people
when they approach 80 years old.
This is combining with Joe Biden's lifelong
stutter to make him talk in a particular way.
But these are not my opinion.
These experts, mental health and neurological
experts said they did not see the same things
in Biden that they saw with Trump.
That was their opinion.
OK, having not personally examined Trump nor
Joe Biden, that was the opinion they came
away with.
Now, I've been clear we shouldn't lie to ourselves
and others and say Joe Biden is just Joe Biden
in twenty twenty one is just like he was in
2012 when he ran circles around Paul Ryan
in the vice presidential debates.
If we were to say that it's obviously untrue
and we lose credibility.
70 year old Joe Biden in 2012 humiliated vice
presidential candidate Paul Ryan when Romney
was running against Barack Obama.
Joe Biden had a rapidity and a slickness and
a facility when debating that he did not have
in twenty twenty one debating Donald Trump.
There's no question about it.
This is common in people when they get past
the age of 75.
Now, I'm I'm not I'm not trying to be offensive.
We have lots of folks in our audience in their
70s, in their 80s, even in their 90s.
I'm thinking of our friend Sam in Cambridge,
vibrant, energized in his 90s and a big supporter
of the show.
But if you think about this on a bell curve
at age 78, lots of people are not as energetic
as they were earlier in life.
This is the reality of humanity.
So having without question conceded that,
does Joe Biden know what he's signing?
Is Susan Rice actually the president behind
the scenes?
This is ridiculous to be proposing on a national
cable news channel for Maria Bartiromo and
Larry Kudlow to be doing.
It's outrageous and absurd.
And of course, you simply have to see Joe
Biden answer questions from the press, as
he's done half a dozen times in the two weeks
he's been president, to understand he knows
what he's signing.
He knows what he wants to do about this or
that.
He can talk in detail about pandemic response
and who's on his staff and so on and so forth.
You only need to watch five minutes of that
to know that he understands the things that
are going on, at least politically, because
that's what he's talking about.
So they lost the election.
They tried to then steal it, and that failed.
And now they're resorting to this.
And by the way, most Americans like the things
that Biden has done so far.
You know, Kudlow saying this is the furthest
left president ever.
Well, maybe on paper that's actually true,
but he hasn't really done that much yet.
He's reversed some of the things Trump did
and gotten us back to where we were with Obama.
But these extreme leftist tendencies of Biden
that are being claimed so far, he's not actually
acted on any of them if they exist.
And and for the most part, the country is
relatively pleased with Joe Biden.
Sixty three percent approval in general of
Joe Biden much.
Higher than Trump ever got at any point during
his presidency.
Sixty nine percent approval for Joe Biden's
coronavirus response so far, 80 percent support
for Joe Biden's federal mask mandate.
And on and on and on.
So not only does Joe Biden know what he's
doing, most of the country likes what Joe
Biden is doing so far.
So just absolutely wacky, irresponsible stuff
there on Fox News.